Hi.
I'm Ibrahim Ulukaya from YouTube
API Developer Relations team.
If you are an apps
developer, and you
are trying to find the best way
to start integrating YouTube
APIs into your app, we have
great news for you guys.
We open sourced YouTube
Direct Lite for iOS recently.
And this project demonstrates
the best practices
for using the YouTube
APIs inside your app,
such as using the YouTube Data
API, YouTube Data API uploads,
as well as the iFrame
embedded player.
And YouTube Direct
Lite is actually
a platform itself for that.
People can solicit
videos from their users,
so that their users can submit
videos to their playlist,
so that they can
moderate and choose
which videos to show
up in that playlist.
And for that, inside the
app, users can actually
use this app so that they
can record any video,
or they can pick any video that
they have recorded earlier,
and upload to YouTube and
submit to your playlist,
as well as they can pick any
video they already uploaded
to YouTube before, and then
still submit to your playlist.
And let's go to my screen and
actually see it from here.
So the project is
also under github.
It's under
github.com/youtube/yt-direct-lite-iOS.
And in this project, we are
using the Objective-C client
libraries for Google
APIs so that it handles
the authorization and
it makes it really easy
to talk with the
YouTube Data API.
Let's go to project itself and
see the project from there.
Here actually starts with
the authorization OAuth 2.0,
and [? I key ?]
[? in the ?] authorization.
And we are logging
into my account,
and we are authorizing
this app to use my account.
The app is going through,
and it's actually
going through my playlist
style plus playlist,
and pulling all the
playlist items from there.
And through the videos list
called, for all these videos,
it brings up the videos'
titles, the view count,
as well as the video duration.
And it also bring in the
YouTube thumbnails as well.
So if you click in
off the videos here,
we are actually [? instating ?]
the YouTube iFrame embedded
player.
And here it's using
Apple's own streamer.
If you want to go for the full
screen, that's one option.
Or from the iFrame
embedded playing options,
you can set plays
inline [? once ?]
so the player actually
will play the video
inside the application.
So after seeing any video, we
can submit it to a playlist.
Or we can record a complete
new video with the camera.
Or we can pull one of
the videos I have already
saved in my iOS device.
And from there I can
actually play the video
before, same thing,
and if I'm sure I want
to upload this video playing,
I can set a new title,
and I can start the video.
Right now we are using the
YouTube Data API resumable
uploads, so the upload is going
on in the background, as well.
And once the
upload's finished, it
will show us its ID, the video
ID that's already uploaded.
See the video is uploaded,
we get the video's ID,
and this video, besides
uploading to my account,
it already is submitted
to the playlist
that I want to submit for.
Here was the YouTube
Direct Lite for iOS.
So in this project,
we demonstrated
the YouTube Data
APIs, such as you
actually pull from
the user's playlist.
We used the iFrame
embedded player
so that we will be able to play
those users' YouTube videos,
as well as we used the data API
uploads, the resumable uploads,
so that we were able to
upload videos to YouTube.
And you can use this project to
start your application, instead
of starting from scratch,
as well as we can go here
to find the best
examples, as well.
Thanks for listening today.
I am Ibrahim Ulukaya
from YouTube.